you know it's [ __ ] exciting what is
it our highlights channel it has clips
of the show in case you didn't have time
to watch full episode or you're just
like oh there's just one part in the
episode of really like but I can't
remember what time stamp it was watch
the clips channel all bite-sized
conversations instead of the entire
episode just for you at hey [ __ ]
highlights subscribe hey yes like just
just said you get an all-star introduce
yourselves you find pieces of assets
it's us it's bows TIFF hi it's Gina hi
it's me Geo
hi it's Nikki hello about some sexy [ __ ]
let's go before I even say anything else
I'm gonna keep you guys in suspense
right now this episode is brought to you
by buff their latest product the breeze
that what you need right now actually
try that [ __ ] out girl yes it is a
comforter made entirely from a hundred
percent eucalyptus fiber to regulate
temperature and keep you cool and
comfortable Oh $20 off your Buffy
comfort or visit Buffy Co that's dot Co
and enter code b tch okay yes baby girl
since you already brought it up and like
you got your [ __ ] juices flowing what
are we gonna talk about today I think
we're gonna talk about oba trans with
benefits yes you're not sure though I
think I just knew it was a sex topic
because we have like we have like like a
cup nice topics and then we have like
these are the sex topics of beer are
like resident nasty I love that you
[ __ ] are that way okay uh yes that's
correct we are talking about friends
with benefits whose
had them who likes them who doesn't even
know that they're even that friend with
the benefit and they think they're in a
relationship cover all oh yeah it's cool
so I've been in a couple of one-sided
friends but benefit really one side
though yeah I was I will get there can
we define what a friends with benefit is
because we you know we might have some
people I would like a friend with health
benefits because those benefits work at
9:00 to 5:00 so I can reap the rewards
of your benefits we're doing a skit like
that
I was actually yeah I forgot about that
but they didn't talk about health
insurance they talked about like Netflix
and passwords
no with a healthy nine-to-five you can
have health insurance for under $50 a
month [ __ ] you both yeah wait I think I
pay about twenty three dollars for
Anthem Blue Cross I paid $600 I've
raised Rolfing health mom on enhanced
PPO which isn't a PPO it acts like an
HMO that oh my god go through anyone
every month really every month 600 you
$600 of I feel like $100 doctor visits I
pay a thousand plans I have a kid too
dude hold on guys
new topic health and that gets me wet
you got health insurance right the
sideways oh speaking of health insurance
I once [ __ ] a guy so good that he was
like I think I'm gonna put you on my
health insurance
Wow I was dating him okay well what is a
friends-with-benefits here you know what
is looking what is I think this is when
okay let's say you've known somebody for
it could be a few weeks could be a few
months a few in a few years and you sit
they kind of look you show them you're
like I think we might be sexually
compatible but we don't want a date
let's [ __ ] around let's enjoy the sex I
think it's you guys are both just in it
for the sex and enjoy
the feeling and there's no strings
attached what's the difference between
that and a booty call there's even less
you call you benefits oh okay I don't
think I've ever had that okay the
friends have benefits I feel like it's
more like you guys the booty call she's
like yell it's [ __ ] my friends with
benefits like we're kind of right if you
could still go to a movie yeah a little
bit but not get to romance yeah then the
booty call just calls you up at 2:00 in
the morning that's it yeah ever yeah
booty call you might have just met them
on tinder and you've only hung out once
or twice attender that's all Casey and I
were supposed to start at 10 degrees at
10 degrees no a friends with benefits Oh
cuz like we would hang out but every
single time we saw each other we had to
have sex as a passion was haha but you
guys didn't want to be I didn't well I
didn't want to because I just got out of
a really serious relationship mmm like
this was just like a month later is when
Casey and I started seeing each other
but we I made it perfectly clear like
listen I do not want to be in a
relationship just want to hoo
I just wanted a ho I wasn't meant to be
into good girl yeah so like I mean it
was awesome though when I it was like
friends with benefits but then we just
what's awesome about it I liked the fact
that I didn't have to stress out about
maintaining a relationship like I didn't
have to worry about like oh I got a text
amor like I am wanting him to text me or
like let me know where he is or like I
don't know like just having those like
relationship pressures it wasn't there
in the beginning but then once we
started getting more and more in into
our relationship and like that I love
yous came out and then that's when I was
like oh wait this is not a
friends-with-benefits situation in too
deep yeah yeah but it was cool the sex
was awesome but there's almost good uh
let me hear your story because you were
you did you know that you were
friendzone look basically I mean look I
essentially for my entire [ __ ] life
got into relationships non-stop for the
wrong reasons
like in every single time it was a
different situation and then the guys
that I actually
dated I was dating them to validate
myself because I usually kind of dated
above my level you know and so like I
was like oh great I trapped him okay I'm
bored now next so like my in and I'm you
know I'm not ashamed to say that because
like it's learning experience that's
what happened you don't do that anymore
I don't do that anymore I'm I have
healthy relationships for myself and
others but there were but in that same
vein I was looking for people to
validate me and so I would also like
often chase after guys that would never
date me and the reason I was trying to
chase after them was because I wanted
them to date me so that I could validate
myself and feel worthy and so I would
like chase after guys and like we'd go
on dates we might have sex or something
and like it wasn't like a lot you know
like millions there might have been like
three or four that like over the course
of 15 year at 10 years didn't work out
but I would like pursue them and sex was
a component in that and I've never been
a sexual person I didn't enjoy sex it
was like nothing out of it but we would
have sex more than once and so in their
eyes I'm a friend's benefit and in my
eyes I'm on the hunt I'm on the pursuit
the chase and once again I have no
problem saying that because I know
there's hella other girls that are
[ __ ] insane like me they did that [ __ ]
yeah you know and you know you just got
to be like open about it but I never
like have entered into a like hey let's
have sex with each other relationship
yeah never and you would never want to
step all over anyone right oh here we go
like if you have you know there's a
fetish out there for people who like to
be stepped on with beautiful shoes from
ShoeDazzle a new way to spoil women who
love fashion and lust after shoes I
actually use this before when I like
started like really kind of like sort of
making money I'm like I must spoil
myself real quick oh so it's like a
subscription kind of thing a personal
experience every woman gets her own
showroom each month with items based on
her own personal styles so you take a
quick C a 60-second style quiz and
you'll receive a personalized showroom
of pieces specifically catered towards
your own unique style so mine was like a
lot of black
buckles and spikes so they release
brand-new styles like every month and
then also if you come a VIP you save 30
to 50 percent and VIPs can get free
shipping on orders over $39 and have
access to members only sales also
there's no commitment to order monthly
as a VIP so to get your first ShoeDazzle
style for as low as $10 that's Wow 75%
Wow all right yes oh yeah you're about
to break glass girl off your first item
with your with our special link it's
ShoeDazzle comm /bt
CH to take advantage of this deal so go
to ShoeDazzle calm slash b tch to get
your first style for as low as $10
that's sh OU e d ZZ l e.com /b t don't
miss out make sure to enter your email
address okay once you take the style
quiz as you'll receive exclusive monthly
discounts on your suit oh man I want
some thuth yes yeah well I mean who Jess
are we gonna go straight into Jess or
should we like to go straight into me
okay baby
honestly I don't think that I've ever
had a friends with benefits situation
surprisingly no because every guy that I
try to do that with I wind up in some
sort of relationship with I don't know
if I could do it for very long there
would have to be a reason like maybe we
were dating ten years ago and I know I
don't like him but I he had a good day I
haven't gotten to that point yet so um
I'm kind of curious like maybe I will
try that now that I'm single again
oh honey damn you know or not yet no no
don't DM her I'm not accepting any
application I'm waiting in the wings she
needs to heal I've got my dick already
loaded on that when I fingers on the
send button right now
the wings exams 8 you ready you ready no
fans if you know who I am before we go
on a date we're not going on the date
right just so you know right no it's not
good I tried doing it three times tried
to have friends with benefits because
the thing is I was in back-to-back
serious relationships so I hadn't been
single for seven years because I went
straight from a five-year into a
two-year and then it was my first time
in my 20s ever being single and I was 26
and so I was like I want to try like
casually dating and the thing is if I go
longer than six weeks without having sex
I want to [ __ ] anyone that walks by me
like I jakey do you know how I feel
right now
do we look really sexy right
[Laughter]
no what's [ __ ] up is that Bryce is
sitting right next door but George's are
set daddy okay George strut daddy if
it's been six months or six weeks I
would [ __ ] you yeah I got you buddy I
got you buddy so yeah after six weeks of
my single hood I was like I need to [ __ ]
and so I would you know like I did
stand-up comedy and so I would just hang
around because like most of them were
guys that were stand-ups and the guy
that made me laugh the most after you
know and um like a checklist like a
meter know if they made that made me
it's seven no it's been a thing Nikki
have you ever gone to a stand-up show
and you're like well that one's a laugh
daddy like that one's a laugh daddy I
labeled them no yeah I definitely like
have an immediate attraction where I'm
like I can see us [ __ ] like if they
made me laugh a certain way or a certain
amount or that like guttural deep laugh
and so you're gonna say that vaginal
laughs you make my vagina giggle Mattie
you ready
believe me I several times I tried were
like I'd hang out with a guy let me to
have a really great night like we'd go
to like different like concerts and it
was it was really fun like a fun time
and I knew I didn't want to date because
I didn't feel those like loving vibes I
just wanted to have fun like go hang out
like they were good conversationalist
and I wanted to [ __ ] and I told them
that before having sex I'm like just so
you know I don't know what kind of
emotional place you're in but I'm not at
all wanting to date anyone and I feel a
flex flex honest girl no it's not a flex
kryptonite you figured it out yeah then
I would we'd have sex and then they
immediately would start treating me like
we were in a relationship how they
wanted to take me out to nice dinners it
started getting more like romantic and
I'm like this is not the fun and the
[ __ ] that I signed up for it so many
like that's so strange that you had that
experience when so many guys feel like
that like throughout their whole like
adult life they're like I didn't sign up
for a [ __ ] relationship [ __ ] this
one and it [ __ ] you but now you have the
insight and I yeah and I thought this is
what all guys want like so it'll work
out because I'm at that place where like
I don't want a relationship at all and
not only that but I couldn't even
emotionally get there like to it because
I was still kind of heartbroken over my
last relationship I just wanted fun and
yeah so jess just be warned like you
think that's what all guys will go crazy
for but turns out they want a
relationship but I'm gonna pick any
happy times in a row
later I had to like let these guy I was
like hey I just wanted a wife you were
like we had a conversation beforehand
and they're like yeah I thought that was
something you were saying all three
times how are we speaking English I know
a girl really means that no yeah you
know I'm just gonna say ladies take
notes from Nikki because if my technique
was I'm not gonna [ __ ] them through two
months or three and then and then you
know it kind of just blew
Nikki's mother lucky let's go if you're
down if they're like hot enough to do it
then like tell them I don't want to do
anything serious and then and then
that's so true I remember when Casey and
I went on her first like unofficial date
and back then I was like solid like no
yeah this is not happening like we're
not
not even the friends-with-benefits part
happened yet and I was telling him like
dude I just got out of this relationship
like I'm nothing that same night he was
putting his handle on my hips fluff and
like trying to get all close to me and
so I'm like and then later on once we
started dating I'm like dude why did you
do that like I told you that same night
I didn't want anything happy wife yeah
why he's like a Jew like I guess yeah no
no he said the same thing that your guy
said which was I didn't think you meant
it I see you work I would say that
because why would you hang out on a
one-on-one that's like even if it's an
unofficial date it's because I want to
[ __ ] yeah it was for her but for me
other people were supposed to be there
oh yeah that makes sense
oh my god I got you that makes a lot of
sense yeah but but when I met Steve or
when we started dating I said I love you
within 10 days like I told you like I
was emotionally ready I knew I wanted I
knew it was him I knew he was the one so
it wasn't like it was a tactic where I
was like hey I just want to [ __ ] I'm
cool girl that just you know like I
really was not emotionally available
then and then when I was emotionally
available I was like hey you're the one
and I love you and let's get married how
do you know when you're not emotionally
emotionally available like when I win
that romantic key stuff that I I'm such
a romantic and if I picture them doing
that to me it makes me queasy
instead of like accepting of it how do
you want to [ __ ] them then because it's
separate it's compartmentalized I used I
know but I could only [ __ ] someone I had
feelings for until this period in my
life where I was so heartbroken over I
was like I was grieving this past
relationship but I was still horny like
my hormones were still it's called it's
called grief boning
yeah it's grief bone I feel like that's
like not the most attractive thing to a
man if you're like what do I do and I'm
lonely and horny really putting myself
out there like that I was like you see
you're funny and you seem like a good
guy that doesn't have STDs but let's
work on him anyway I'm ready to [ __ ]
let's just do it yeah
my god yeah Greece banging is very
strong yeah yeah what's in drums a cuz
you're like emotional and the guys like
oh let me fix me really save you and
then the grief bang happens and yeah
yeah but then they're like I thought
this was going somewhere this one guy
like kept sending me selfies of himself
in my own yeah Nikki did you feel like
you were friends with them or you wanted
to be friends with them yeah a father a
good time like they were funded like
they were spontaneous we got we were
like oh you want to go to this thing
like my friends have in this thing a lot
of scar girl let's go to that and like
it was was fun was like sponte and I
never had that I never had like someone
that was just really willing to just go
on adventures and it was all three guys
were comedians and all three guys were
like really fun and they were like cool
to have deep conversations with stuff
that I really like in a relationship but
emotionally not available at all and
when two of them after we had sex
wanted to spend the night and cuddle and
I couldn't sleep at all that night like
I just wanted to vomit the entire night
because that like intimacy like that
like cuddling thing I was so repulsive
to me after having sex and that's how I
like that's how you know you're not
emotionally available that's not I never
had I never had I think I was really
guilty I just felt like I don't know
what it was I was just like super
prideful even though I didn't need to be
where I was like one no one's gonna talk
about me like they [ __ ] had me like I
always had to feel like I had like to
have control in the relationship like
yeah get them yeah exactly like I always
feel like I felt like I had to have like
the upper hand in that you know like now
looking back my thought was so [ __ ]
stupid so I think most of my
relationships were probably been friends
with benefits for me at least but for
them it was probably like really serious
Wow yeah I was really [ __ ] up I've
grown a lot
I mean like I feel like it's not what
you hold it that was it then yeah that
wasn't considering their feelings
god I just thought that you could tell
they were definitely interested in you
and you didn't put down those boundaries
of like I don't want to go into early
no I wanted the relationship because I
thought [ __ ] with it and outside or
just having sex outside of a
relationship was bad like I felt like a
[ __ ] like those beliefs like yeah
exactly like I just felt like uh like
just anyone has access to my body and
I'd like I didn't want that see for me
that's oral sex I won't give a [ __ ]
unless I have feelings for you my rule
is I don't blow you first yeah go down
on me first and then I'll talk about it
yeah why is that it's a power thing for
me for me it's too intimate like since I
don't you don't get like pleasurable
like feelings like the pleasure comes
from pleasing that person right not from
your mouth having a g-spot yeah you
don't want to for me to feel pleasure
from giving a [ __ ] means I care about
you as a person and I like love
pleasuring you yeah and then I have no
it's like completely selfless because I
don't have any other like pleasure you
have sex with a guy unless I I looked at
him and said I want to suck your dick
like immediately if I don't feel that
we're not having sex
yeah I'm well no I'll just do it well I
don't know about you I to me I have when
your wieners in my mouth completed hot
dying you're like your weight out of
looking cold refrigerator like plastic
near my molars I have to say no just
kidding
um but no it's more so because I am i I
didn't value myself in sex a lot I don't
think and so like I I don't know I never
in like I don't like I don't like oral
sex being performed on me I hate it
I absolutely [ __ ] hate it like it's
this job do you know even though yeah I
don't like I do not like it at all
yeah it's just like I'm gonna talk about
it why I mean I I okay I think that it's
like - I think it's too personal I also
because I as a person did not enjoy sex
I don't get any pleasure from it you
know you um you're thinking ever seen it
like talked about like intimacy issues
because I used to feel that way too and
then when I realized everyone was
talking about liking that stuff and then
I didn't I saw a therapist and like
opened up and turns out that I had like
really strong intimacy issues where I
was all about pleasuring them in sex but
I
had a hard time opening up and like
letting them pleasure me it didn't feel
pleasurable cuz I was maybe maybe it
comes from like insecurity to feeling
like you don't deserve pleasure or
anything I mean that absolutely could be
it but yeah I could never have one-night
stands or anything but if I did I would
have a Buffy comforter that's the best
way to impress your part I need to get
one or non partner anybody that comes
over ladies gentlemen
sisters and misters gets you a Buffy
comforter it makes they make bedding
that is earth friendly and cruelty-free
I mean the latest product the breeze is
a comforter made entirely from a hundred
percent eucalyptus fiber to regulate
temperature to keep you cool and
comfortable all night long no more night
sweats softer than cotton hyper
hypoallergenic and a hundred percent
plant-based bedding now that I've read
everything on this card let me tell you
how much I love this blanket I woke up
at 5:00 a.m. this morning with my man
and we were just sleeping under a sheet
I said boy I'm turning on the AC and
we're getting the buffy it just makes me
feel I'm not kidding it just makes me
feel like secure ok it's so freakin cozy
when it's on your bed it looks like a
little cloud you just ready to jump in
there oh my god I loved that blanket
yeah I do I did you know you can go to
Buffy Co I'm go look at this sheet you
can go to Buffy comb and order yours
with 20% I'm sorry $20 off with the code
beep TCH
Buffy offers a free child ladies and
germs you can try a comforter in your
own bed for free and if you don't love
it return it at absolutely no cost
that's the deal but you're not gonna
return it no for $20 off your Buffy
comforter visit Buffy CO and into the
code BT CH mmm once again that's $20 off
your Buffy comforter going to Buffy dot
Co and enter b tch hey baby
like your little sneeze those well thank
you alright so I'm excited to introduce
bomba oh yes I love socks yes
I love these socks I have had these
socks for many years now I actually
bought them from an ad ads work yeah but
no I don't like this one should work
exactly hopefully this works for you
guys because I absolutely love Bamba so
I bought the no-show socks and the
reason why they sold me on these socks
was because you know how for no-show
sucks they always slip off like I do
yeah I hate it yeah so they actually
reinforced these socks with like
multiple layers of like this gummy stuff
that actually holds on to it looks like
a glue gun type tape oh yeah like that
but not as thick oh uncomfortable okay I
love them and they also have arch
support so I have a really high arch in
a saw yeah in a song Pam I have a higher
arch too yeah go you try these running
buy some right now no they are not I am
okay don't tell me my life to you okay
well I guess we're gonna have to pause
this entire thing thank you why need
percent off on your first purchase when
you shop at bombas com slash b tch yes
bombo's dot-com slash b tch to save 20%
off your first purchase I love them
you're gonna love them you will love
that try them out they make great
Christmas presents so that's bombas
dot-com slash b tch
so it's bombas as in b o m b8 s dot-com
slash b tch I really hope it's
pronounced bombas cuz I'd be [ __ ]
funny that [ __ ] that she's Latin izing
it probably is but I can't help it so
what are some of the problems
no but seriously like I'm like listening
to you guys speak and I'm like like
living vicariously through you guys cuz
I'm like damn this is really dope that
you guys were so empowered and and just
understood your self so much that you
guys were like no this is what I want
these are my boundaries these are like
this is for me [ __ ] you like I won't
really not [ __ ] you but it was like this
is for me I got you I wanted to [ __ ] but
then I'm trying to think of like how
does it affect one negatively or like
like yeah like are there's like side
effects it seems like often one party
exactly is not into the idea of just
being casual friends with benefits like
some person develops feelings I actually
got accused of that too with the fourth
cut that I tried doing that way
he said that like he was the one that
was like no you're gonna get feelings
and you're gonna fall in love with me
I'm like maybe not what it's like dried
me up but then we're gonna call it quit
yeah I slept with him and then after
then we're gonna do it again and then he
was like who's like where do you see
this going I was like I told you I just
want to like have sex and have fun and
then he's like see people say that but
then they catch feelings and like I feel
like you're gonna fall in love with me
and I'm not ready for that yet and I was
like don't like turn it on me your dick
have to be to say trust me I'm not gonna
back you sweetheart maybe that was just
weak game so we never talked to get and
then like three weeks later I was dating
Steve and it was over I feel like I
would be the person in that but he
probably looked at that like see I knew
she was that fall in love with me I feel
like I would be the person in the
relationship that would fall for someone
and like how would I like to
then you wouldn't you shouldn't be in a
friends with benefit thing yeah so if I
feel like if someone sets clear
boundaries with you and us yeah hey geo
I want to I think you're a good time and
I like your [ __ ] but I'm not
emotionally available
I think rush you still have sex and then
you'd say but I would like them so much
that I'm like you suck you could win
them over
uh no I'm like please just like like me
maybe yeah yeah maybe yeah yeah maybe
see I think that's what it is for the
other party is like it's more of a
challenge but it's like you kind of like
hurt their ego in a bit they're like no
I'll show you you're gonna yeah and then
you and then they when it doesn't happen
it kind of a set yes oh I was gonna say
like kind of piggybacking off with that
I think my question is so what exactly
exactly separates a friends of benefits
from a relationship so like in front of
benefits you have friendship and getting
along with somebody and sex and then in
a relationship you have you know getting
along with somebody in sex and like what
what else the emotional availability
being able to Mantic being able to like
sleep with other people - like the whole
openness part of the friendship yeah
yeah with friends within of benefits you
still have the same lifestyle that you
do in you're single you don't change
anything you don't have to call them and
tell them what
you can tell them why you're going away
what about like an open relationship if
they're like we love each other we have
mutual respect for each other
yeah I love you I love your friend I
didn't feel like but not like romantic
love wrap so that's the difference I
guess I'm kind of curious you know for
people like me that have trouble with
that how would you guys do to turn your
brain off and to be emotionally
unavailable in it I didn't choose to
yeah I don't think you just weren't
interested no I was grieving my past
relationship like I could physically my
emotions were like we can't handle any
more emotions we're shutting down and
I'm like I'm really emotional as a
person and so I'd never experienced that
before like that was the first time for
me where this part shut down but then my
hormones were like we still want to [ __ ]
yeah I think it's like that age in life
- I'm very fertile you know 26 I think
before when I was single I was 18 or
something like that and so I wasn't
quite there yet but 26 I was like my
body was like I don't care if you can't
handle a relationship but we need to
[ __ ] yeah interesting yeah I I can't
even imagine myself then cuz I did have
that where I broke up with my boyfriend
and I was really sad not because I broke
up with him but I was just like so down
on myself for wasting so much [ __ ]
time and I was crying and I just wanted
to be left alone and I did have a friend
that I was really close to but I never
once thought of [ __ ] him or like
several guy friends actually like sex
wasn't even in my brain me it was like
someone brushes my arm and I'm like oh
we gotta [ __ ] that moment over when I
wanted to do like when I wanted to do
like a friends-with-benefits thing it
was for me I had already checked out of
the relationship I was in like a while
back like I was already like finally I'm
free oh my god I could breathe in it I
guess like emotionally maybe because I
had so much time to like detach myself
from that person by the time I met Casey
I didn't realize it but I think I was
already emotionally available available
for him but it was more like it was more
like I wanted to experience a freedom
from a relationship that's what I really
like yeah so then once he started
getting like emotionally like attached
and we both
getting emotionally attached a little
part of me did kind of get a little bit
bummed out cuz I'm like well I really
wanted to see what that freedom would be
like because I ever since I was 16 I had
always been in a relationship and with
one month Wow being single between each
one
yeah Wow so like two months yeah of like
since I was 16
being singles I've never got to
experience that but it was really
beautiful then once we fell in love and
like all that it's like you didn't
choose it it shows you exactly but a
little part of me is just like damn it I
missed out to just no you didn't because
the pool out there is just like and this
sex is the quality of sex is different
right mm-hmm
I mean it's been a well Oh over five
years now since I've been single and I
remember I think like it just depends on
how much sure you are what you're like
really what your intentions are like are
you just trying to serve your own ego or
like what like what's really behind your
choices too and that's gonna determine
like who you pick and then how the sex
is I feel like because a lot of it is
emotional but yeah you can I don't know
it's hard to say I'm I'm gonna find out
how the pool is in LA though I'll take
about in Texas I feel like the pool was
really small and there's just a lot of
you know country bumpkins so I'm really
excited to be in the Greater Los Angeles
area
you know flirty Talisman million people
here 30,000 people move here every day
yes coming for me and 30,000 people
leave every day oh my god but 30,000 new
people come to a blue moon flossing it
was out of here we have so much traffic
we have so much okay I'm welcoming them
they need to come I need with legs open
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is there any like would you guys that
have successfully had friends with
benefit would you recommend it are you
like this is something that I feel like
everyone should try like kind of like
you should live with someone before you
like you know in a relationship I think
that of a success I have a new date I
haven't told my story oh yeah if you're
quiet yeah
when you have Wyatt I was just waiting
waiting in the wings man I told you yes
um so I have a friend who I've known
since I was like 17 years old and we
were like boning back then it was dope
and it was just cool like we got along
like we went to school together we got
along like we would watch movies
together and stuff but we never for some
reason we never discussed like I think
we both came like we don't want to be in
a relationship and more than ten years
later now we're still like really close
best friends
it's dope and you still [ __ ] no okay
yeah but we [ __ ] for a little bit and
then we just became friends it was cool
yeah and like now when we hang out we
there's like no sexual anything at all
just like you I love you
and then yeah so we still check in on
each other all the time we're gonna
probably we're gonna get matching
tattoos soon Wow yeah cuz we're like
that like we're friends now like this is
buttoned oh yeah so that's my self came
from a friends with - exactly yeah and
then the second time that actually tried
it this is when I was like did I die
yeah the second time that I actually
tried it this is when I was like out of
relationship and I was like you know
what I'm just gonna [ __ ] right so I met
this guy we hung out had sex and then I
was and then I was like so cool like
yeah I'm gonna spend the night you know
like it's you know you don't even need
to know like my last name or anything my
real last name whatever and then
updating him for a year I'm much more of
a relationship yeah I love to love you
know but yeah my friend I'm like more
than a decade ago that's our that's I
feel as my success story because it
didn't and we got to see in the group
chat huge dinner masters it's hiding
behind my master hi if you're listening
he actually saw the episode where else
about him he's like dude can you please
be a little bit more like history
the screen like [ __ ] like hell yeah
that's well I mean he and I our story
was different we were kind of looking up
and then started to like each other but
it didn't work out but we remained
friends and we're still really close
friends now like he like he has his own
life whatever and we just checking every
once awhile like is that called instead
of friends with benefits like friends
with exes friends without benefits
yeah friends oh it's just called friends
yeah friends thank you sorry that you
[ __ ] that you don't [ __ ] any man
that's a really long title yeah friends
Xbox buddies yeah there you go
but yeah I think that's my success story
we're like super close friends though
that effort Boas were like a few months
damn damn I had this really good [ __ ]
question then I started thinking about
it that was so good everything about his
video video I didn't see the video I
watched the video and I pulled all the
girls together I was like yo you know we
remember the one that can [ __ ] his own
bellybutton I felt like cheating so like
I'm like I'm not gonna look because I
just saw your dick I don't even want I
contact get away somebody I told him
like I told the girls he's like damn it
G know why [ __ ] his own bellybutton yeah
yeah I did and he was not black I was
surprised I married it anyway that to
answer your question earlier about do
you think everyone should go through
that phase of having a friends with
benefits
I think it for me I would always wonder
what that was like to like go through
casual sex without being a serious
relationship if I had never tried it so
I feel like I got it out of my system
yeah I think it would be a lot easier to
have friends with benefits when you get
older maybe after 30 35 because your
more mature all it and who you are yeah
you know what your life is yeah kind of
like doing everything like trying to
find who you are like latching onto
people for your own self-esteem like I
do a lot yeah you're early 20s for me I
would say don't even try that [ __ ] when
you're super young like just wait till
you get what super young to you I'm like
21 22 because I'm so emotionally like
[ __ ] also the guys are immature - yeah
so like especially if you're in college
and you're like you think you're doing
this healthy thing with friends with
benefits it's not yeah you don't know
what that guy's saying to his friends
what he's doing because if you're both
very immature at that time and friends
with benefits is a very mature thing
yeah it really is yeah it's easier just
to like have sex and then maybe kind of
just cut it off like if you know like
I'm I'm very emotional right now I want
someone to love me like you're setting
yourself up for failure by allowing
yourself to like accept the fact that he
doesn't want a relationship so like
think about what you really want in your
life so being in tune with you and what
your emotional needs are I think is
healthy yeah cuz then I'm also thinking
here like what about those people that
like they start off that way because
they're so insecure and they're just
like hoping that it kind of leads into
or they use that as a crutch no and what
are you asking me no you didn't you use
it as a crutch no no before that you
were like they're so insecure and no I'm
like saying this is a good thing like
what what's your question I can help
oh yeah like yeah like they're so
insecure that they use that like as an
excuse or like as a way to like
infiltrate and be like say oh I'm okay
with being friends with yes absolutely
and guys I'm gonna tell you right right
now watch the [ __ ] out for me like
people thank you because seriously like
we will we will act and like I say this
to be an open book for the girls to do
this and also the guys that may not see
this like we will literally say oh we're
cool Oh everything's cool I'm literally
at home waiting for you to text me and
like I said I do not do this anymore
but like it come dude it comes from like
just a lot of different things that
culminate but it's its overall
insecurity you know and like I'm very
I'm kind of thinking I'm trying to think
now like how can guys like sense this
that was my follow up yeah keep it going
let me think I can really really answer
what you think about that we're going to
take a
breaked to talk about hinge oh yeah so
I'm not in a dating space anymore but
just hearing about everyone's experience
like George who's behind us seeing the
guy that you always hear laughing uh and
Jess you got to tell us about your
experience I'm just kind of a little bit
jealous I mean I just downloaded it like
a few days ago and I'm really excited
but also scared but the thing that like
makes it cool is I actually really like
this app compared to it well so the last
time I signed up for an app that was
like six years ago before my last
relationship and I was on you know the
other major ones I never tried hinge the
thing I noticed immediately was like the
profile design was like super thoughtful
like you have to flange yeah for here
did the other one compared to the yeah
yeah you have to like download or I'm
sorry upload a minimum number of
pictures so it's not just like one photo
that kind of sucks like and it's fake
usually people yeah they always put like
the the angle or they have like filters
yeah yeah so this way like you're gonna
get to see them in several photos minim
minimum is several photos and I like
that and then also like that you have to
answer a certain number of questions
because there's this other app and they
will remain unnamed but you just kind of
like have this chance to fill out one
line and it's kind of like what do you
put yeah oh I don't know what to say in
that one I feel like people are getting
sick of dating apps because they're all
about hooking up but then there's people
that are like no I really want to
establish a connection and like um like
of a relationship and none of these
other apps are doing it yeah I mean all
about swiping and hook it up yeah it
sounds like that way I mean I've never
seen any of these apps um cuz I've just
been married for like ever
ah but yeah it just sounds like no it
just sounds like it's literally designed
just to hook up because it's that one
line I'm like I'm not gonna get to know
anything about yeah and I feel like I'm
gonna get duped I've had girlfriends
tell me that like guys will write like
their height and then like when they
meet up they would say I'm six-two or
something and then they'll meet up and
they're like five six and they're like
no I would have never known because
there's only one picture yeah the thing
the thing on the height thing is funny
too because I feel like every guy that's
like five six or five seven actually
puts 510 or 511 yeah and what's cool
about hinge
they openly are like we're designed to
be deleted I love because we want you to
find a long-term relationship Thank You
hinge because yes I don't want to be on
dating apps forever I'm 32 I want to
find like a real relationship I mean I
still need a little bit of space except
from my last relationship but right now
I do want to find quality people get to
shop around girls trash people
I don't want trash people know I love
that I love that that's their motto that
it's designed to be deleted because it
gives me hope I'm like well I mean you
get vote for me right you're giddy yes
that's me me I it gives you the hope for
people that need it okay that's all I'm
saying you better get ready she's in her
escape plan I'm happily married okay but
for anyone that's not happily married or
that just you know they want to find
love it sounds like hinge is the way to
go
we saw George's that's the guy that I
keep talking about and his was [ __ ]
cool I got to learn so much about him
like he spent 14 hours in Tokyo and I'm
like man if I would have saw that that'd
be so interesting to me like it's a know
a lot about the person okay yeah so
George has a girlfriend
yeah yeah yeah he deleted it but the
only reason why he had that on his phone
because he took screenshots cuz he
wanted to be cubed I'm gonna put you on
blast for being cute but yes app is
deleted he found the one y'all so yes
make sure you guys go download hinge I
love it so far and they're gonna love
watching me and Gina use it oh hell yeah
I got it okay do like warning signs
warning signs like if if she can't go if
she gets like concern yeah well yeah
getting concerned when you guys don't
talk for a day if they if like I was
interested in somebody and like I was
kind of like doing this whole validation
and security thing I would anticipate we
spoke every day like you can skip a few
days and like if you feel like you can
skip a few days with talking to them and
they actually seem comfortable they're
not passive-aggressive after a few days
I'm not talking like it's probably cool
but if they like find just random waste
hit you up or hey what's up or
responding to your stories and they need
to keep in contact with you every single
day like that's kind of first sign yeah
because when you guys don't talk for a
while they're like oh do they do do you
like me yeah that's a huge sign yeah
absolutely cuz do you guys feel like you
could definitely go a few days without
talking to her friends with benefit oh
dude yeah yeah at this point like don't
call me for three weeks
just give me that good dick well all my
ovulation we get the [ __ ] out of my way
to do but when you're like 21 you know
like me like I don't know where he went
I think another one would be unnecessary
emotion like in the first month or two
like you know when things are starting
out early if you sense passive
aggressiveness like you know maybe kind
of wanting to like hang out a little too
much or them kind of like probing deep
to get to know you a little like deeper
than you need to on a friends with
benefits level that person is interested
in more than just [ __ ] you I disagree
with that one really I just really hate
small talk and love deep conversations
so one of the things I like about a
friends with benefits is someone that's
a really good conversationalist so we
can talk about deep things or what type
of people they are I think she means
more like personal [ __ ] right we get in
a personal [ __ ] family and stuff like
that yeah like what if it pertains to
the experience I feel like that's some
intimate [ __ ] that like to me it's like
I wouldn't even have you as a friend or
like what I don't know what can see both
sides yeah I think if you're seeing a
multiple warning sign yeah yeah you know
like that's the only thing how I treat
everybody yeah is that like I like to
have deep conversations with them they
don't have a conversation yeah we did we
went to lunch and we talked all all
about all of your insecurities do I got
a whole book on you sure no she did hold
a journal page on you prove it I'm sorry
like eight girls - if you feel like
you're doing this [ __ ] but also like I
don't know another thing that I think I
tended to do was I started to almost act
like a girlfriend early like whether it
be like oh I'll pay for this or oh yeah
don't worry I'll grab you and like I
would always act really chill about it
but like I was kind of like in like it's
not intentional like it's not really to
be crazy
I just like it's like in my head I'm
showing you like you know like oh we
haven't exactly you know so like yeah
these are like we've cut if you see all
three of those [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] run
okay I gotta keep being up next morning
if you're trying to have a friends with
benefits relationship yeah trying to get
into a relationship maybe these are
signs if someone's ready to settle down
with you yeah what do you guys think is
a good way for a guy to talk to a girl
if he starts to sense that maybe there's
like more there than he's looking for
and vice-versa like how can a girl talk
to a guy too and be like hey hold on I
would just make up another person be
like hey like I met someone that I
really like okay and I have to cut them
off yeah this would be a deep wound they
can't come back no it's over yeah for
them I would just be like hey I met
someone that I really like so I don't
think we can continue this anymore but
it was really cool you really awesome
have a good day dude if somebody did
that to me I mean that yeah that's
everyone has a now I'm older
whereas before I'd be like yeah [ __ ] it
but now I'm just like you just be
straight up like literally but then
stick to that like don't reply to the
text don't reply to it like you have to
be like hey I'm doing this because I
don't want to hurt your feelings we're
in different places right now and then
when they try to reach out just don't
even say sorry or don't like don't reply
like let the wound here that's why I
have the disclaimer first I'm like so
that you know what you're getting into
I'm very straight up with people but
then yeah so when it gets too far when
I'm like well they're kind of treating
me like a romantic partner and I say hey
remember that conversation I had before
we hooked up usually they're they were
sad but they took it they were like oh
true I just thought it was going to four
direction but one guy cussed me out what
yeah no and he was like here's go go
back to your shitty ex-boyfriend he
started like digging up all of them like
my [ __ ] that's not his business and and
just like yeah I cussed me out and was
like [ __ ] you you're scared and you're
stupid and low suffering and he hung up
on me and I never talked to that guy
again I blocked him on everything but
like that was just for me going like hey
cuz he goes hey what you're not gonna
talk to me tomorrow's like we just
talked and he's like yeah but you know
what I mean
like like you know we just we did stuff
and then now we're not talking like in a
certain way I'm like I'm treating you
exactly how I treated you before we did
stuff because that's what I said I would
do and then he yeah he went off on me
but dude also for insecure people saying
I'm not looking for a relationship it's
like catnip it's like a challenge
it's like you don't want this and if I
like prove if I if I like do this then
I'll validate I think about them
yeah in reality the person who says I
don't want a relationship it is about
inside them own something it doesn't
matter who you are like yeah you can't
change that let me tell you already
cursing someone else not a way to get
them to like you back it's a very
dangerous situation not like literally
but like emotionally it is really really
risky it can be so that's why it also be
literally dangerous that's why it was a
crazy person I say that I'm seeing
someone else and not just hey I don't
really want to do this with you anymore
because then people might go crazy mm-hm
well no they might get crazier if
there's another guy because then they're
gonna shoot his ass Jesus true the ones
I date do do that I'm just like now
because I've [ __ ] up so much in life
and like in love and stuff no oh well in
love in relationships I was just I just
didn't understand him I didn't
understand myself like I've done a lot
of developing over the years and like a
lot of like just like reflect like self
reflecting and like really just trying
to make it about me and fixing that that
like I'm just like be straight up yeah
because then just [ __ ] just snowballs
into something way worse that's maturity
yeah but why do you think that you have
to go through those lessons so when
you're it's good that we're warning
people that are young to like try to
stay away from them but if you do go
through that know that it's learning a
learning experience like you'll
definitely learn and don't take that
into the next relationship and project
these yeah things that happen to you on
to the next relationship use it as like
a learning experience and like grow from
it yeah I mean I'm all about like
experiencing things firsthand because
that's at least the way I retain
information the best yeah um so yeah if
you're curious about it like do it but
then like but know that it's an
experiment and it might hurt you you
know do you think there's an expiration
date
friends would benefit oh well you know
what's funny so you said that you guys
were like [ __ ] for a while and then
stopped and then we're friends for like
ten years mm-hmm
I have another friend that he and his
friend slept together when they were
like 19 or so and now they're 26 27 and
like they [ __ ] like twice and then
they never they never did it again and
they went back to being friends
so like I don't know there's I think
there's something weird when maybe you
would decide that you like this person
so much as a friend that you don't want
to lose them and get lost in a sexual
relationship I don't know it's like me
and him have never had like the feelings
ever so we we never had like the whole
like oh this might [ __ ] up our
friendship it was just always you're
[ __ ] dope like this just hang out
it's really weird yeah I got lucky with
this one yeah but as for like expiration
date I don't know like I feel like
people can be friends with benefits for
ever and ever whatever as long as you
guys are both understanding like it's
possible like let's say you're both
single you both love each other as
friends you both [ __ ] occasionally and
you think that it's sustainable like for
years like until you meet someone that
you actually have feelings for oh my god
but and then like you know we were
talking about the complications of a
friends with benefit imagine like having
a friends with benefits that you were
super comfortable with for four years
and then you guys both think
everything's cool but then one of you
goes and dates someone else and this
person realizes they have feelings for
you all there's a conversation in place
and we have an understanding that it's
just friends with benefits
I just I can't feel too bad if something
you knew and so if you're friends with
benefits when you cut out the benefits
can you still be friends when you're in
a new relationship yeah yeah is it is it
risky though never be friends with any
of those people but that's because they
wanted a relationship okay
and it was never like a weird transition
for us it was just it just happened I
know a couple that they were friends
friends with benefits for many years and
they would each like like when they
would be in relationships they would
just remain friends and not [ __ ] during
that time but then once they stopped
being in a really
they would come back together and then
that's when the [ __ ] would start
again cool her healthy the way I saw it
cuz I don't know I'm on the outside but
eventually they got married and now they
have a little girl
oh whoa Wow that's a good quiz I think
about it I have someone like that to
really yeah but he's like very
respectful like if he's ever in town
he's like you know are you single I'm
like no I'm not I guess all right cool
love you bye and oh yeah it's really
sweet I had a guy do that too up until I
got engaged yeah like I used to go like
nope still with that same guy yeah but
then like he and I are still friends
like I met his family and like we're
like we're and his well I mean like we
were kind of seeing each other sort of
but in the back of my mind I knew wasn't
ever gonna be serious but like I've
known this guy since like middle school
oh right and like I know the family and
the family's cool with me and I still
caught like I just commented on her
vacation photos and stuff like that too
but like we're still friends like we
check in on each other hey you good you
good and then like you know if we're
single then cool love you bye like it's
it's dope wonder how you connect like
how that happens is it just because like
you when you look at this person you're
like I could never actually like take
into my parents and all that but like I
am sexually attracted to him or like
what really stops you from feeling those
feelings like it's such an interesting
thing how you can be like oh I'm dating
someone now and then not be like oh I
think it's because I know him so well
and I knew him like you and I would
probably not work out in a relationship
like I love you as a person as a friend
but seeing you in previous relationships
I know how you are and he's seen me and
we knew that we were not gonna be
compatible but the sex was great so only
healthy to understand I understand each
other and like who you are is like
individuals is that from an outsider
just listening to your guys's story what
it sounds like
I guess answering your question what it
sounds like to me is that we all look
for certain types of qualities that we
want in one person right and they're not
all gonna have that but then when we are
compatible with one person that has that
one quality then we're like okay cool
like we can be friends
[ __ ] you know and that but they don't
possess any of the other ones yeah like
speak but I don't have them of six that
you need to really want to be in a
relation or two yeah for me it wasn't a
checklist it was all about being
emotionally available because those guys
like probably could have been good
partners but I really just yeah couldn't
physically and emotionally be there and
you know make myself heaven or I mean
just selecting to [ __ ] that person oh oh
yeah electing yeah I mean like that yeah
so they have all the things but I just
don't have my emotions there yeah would
you guys be cool if you were dating
somebody and then you just later on
found out they were so really close with
their previous friends with benefits
mhm yeah I'd be I wouldn't like that
yeah I think they should stop talking to
people they had sexual I mean once
you're but I mean like yeah let's say
you're in a relationship with somebody
and you guys are exclusive and he's been
friends with Karen this whole time but
you he later like is open with you let's
say he's open to and says like hey you
know ki yeah Karen and I used to like
you or maybe you've heard here's the
grapevine or maybe go to its coffee with
her and stuff does he hang out with I
mean they're still friends I
okay really yeah I think I had that in
college I was dating this guy he was he
didn't live here I mean he he was coming
to school here but he was originally
from like Oakland and then we started
dating and I think we dated for maybe
like a year close to a year and he told
me about that friend that he did have a
friends with benefits with and he's like
yeah just to let he's like my friends in
town but just to let you know I was like
sexually like I was sexual with her we
never got in a relationship but we do
have that past are you okay with that
and I was like oh [ __ ] that's hot yeah I
thought that was so cool like I think if
they're open about us one thing and I
asked us because we were asking like
what are the complications of her
friends would benefit and like let's say
you are you have an occasional sex
relationship with somebody and you're
great friends but when they finally do
get into a relationship maybe you're
cool with them being in a relationship
but that person's significant other may
not be cool with you guys being friends
I wouldn't be cool with them going and
hanging out solo together but like if
it's just like a friend
we're like if we run into them they're
like oh hey how's it going I don't mind
that yeah it's just like no hangouts
like no going to generous person what
about hangout yeah it's no if we're all
okay like I don't know like there's a
person like that in our circle that like
was kind of that for me and Steve knows
about him and like when we run into each
other in like I don't like events and
stuff it's all cool go out like we would
never just hang out like yeah my friend
that I've known the one that I've been
telling you is for like I'm for my
friend with benefits yeah the guys I
date are pretty truly cuz I'm a friend
about it and it's also because it was
like 12 years ago - you're like he and I
like our friendship upkeep we rarely see
each other like will message each other
on Facebook and stuff but our friendship
upkeep is once a year we go on a super
fancy dinner date and like completely
platonic it's just us getting dressed up
how are you yeah it's really adorable
but when you're in a relationship - yeah
really yeah yeah I want to be okay with
that no yeah what I think I'm thinking I
don't think I'm yeah but with the cello
dates yeah I think it's because like I
need let you know like dude like this
was 12 years ago like this is me my
friend hanging out and we have a lot
[ __ ] again understand that what is
yeah if you want so you can come along
see with that like I don't trust you
yeah I don't trust them it's that they
might still have feelings free but it
doesn't matter yo to me I don't like and
also it's like so why complicate things
with adding in a little bit engine for
sure they don't really need to be in the
picture about the same time Steve is
like a [ __ ] steel door no I know this
is gonna crack him so he places those
rules on me and then it's like it's just
a discussion you know among your like
your own relationship like what's okay
for your partner and yeah and I know for
him if I were to go hang out with some
guy completely platonic and it doesn't
matter if we even had a sexual past if
it was just a someone of the opposite
sex hanging out solo with me he would
not be okay with it even really yeah
yeah
like and by the time like I'm dating a
person already they have they have
already met my friend a bunch of times I
think you use me met him but yeah
they've already met him and they know
like okay yeah you guys are not boning
at all there's no emotion at all so by
the time you know that happens and I'm
like you know we're gonna go on our
friend date they're like all right cool
have fun you know what's funny this
reminds me of one of Casey's friends so
this girl every time he would go back
home
they would always hang out cuz they're
really good friends he says they never
did anything like he was never into her
anything but one time when I was in
Texas uh I was like oh yeah they're
gonna hit up your friend he was like oh
yeah I should hit her up we always hang
out like let's have dinner so he hits
her up she ends up like immediately
being like yeah I'm in town too cuz she
doesn't live in Texas anymore but she
was in town too and there she was like
yeah let's get dinner whatever and he
was like oh yeah my girlfriend's gonna
come too by the way and she was like oh
no I can't I can't make it I told Casey
I'm like dude she totally had feelings
yeah whole time and now that I'm in the
picture like she they never spoke again
as far as I know
so I'm like Dan that's crazy she was a
she was a friend zone but she didn't
really do it yeah if I was really good
friends of the guy and like I had the
opportunity to meet like his girlfriend
or wife of like many years I'd be so
excited but yeah yeah it was truly just
friends yeah great like I'm so happy
you're like taking care of my friend and
you guys love each other but like if she
didn't wanna meet you because they're
her rest in peace girl hmm is there a
way to tell if you're in the front I
don't know okay is there a way that guys
can tell that you've put them in the
friend zone
oh yeah if I was no they can't we've
seen it firsthand you [ __ ] know they
don't know oh yeah
multiple guy at one and they [ __ ]
have no cronies oh my okay I am though I
have like a grand cardinal rule a
certain extent that if I can tell if
someone's interested or if I'm
interested or like if my friends ask me
how do I know they're interested my rule
is are they asking you questions
mm-hmm yeah what do you mean like when
you're talking or texting like
hey how's your day oh it's fine and it's
like okay that means you're not
interested if I was interested I'll be
like oh it's really good I did this in
this well how about you would you today
like if they keep the conversation going
and that's how I know like they're
interested in you and you're like not
really getting a [ __ ] that's how I ended
up in so many relationships that I want
yeah like I'm just friendly with
everybody at the and that's people have
gotten the wrong idea yeah I have gone
okay so this guy that I used to do
stand-up with was visiting LA and he's
like hey let's grab a drink and so I
went across the street cuz I live in
Hollywood and we got a drink together
and I was in my old relationship at the
time but I was going through my pictures
on like yeah like my boyfriend's getting
his own place right now and I was like
showing him pictures of my cats in boxes
and he was like wait did you say
boyfriend I was like yeah yeah it's so
the cats are in the boxes anyway so the
guy was like oh this is awkward and I
was like why and he's like because we're
like on a date right now I'm like wait
why Oh grab a drink like we had never he
had never asked me out on a day he had
never flirted with me like the first
date
he'd only just done stand-up sighs don't
want to be with guys don't just want to
be so comfy yeah also Nikki you're like
hot so if a guy asks you out for a drink
what no it was it but it wasn't like it
never ends like seems like always like
yeah yeah that's happened to me okay
okay colleague thing yeah where we used
to so we used to do shows like every
single weekend together as a group okay
I can see that and then like he was
visiting LA and I hadn't seen him in a
few years and it was never like so you
single not you see me what there was no
conversation like I was like do you want
to grab you never fell it I was like
this is not a date yeah and if this is a
date you did a poor job someone else you
need to be like clear yes
I don't need to know I'm straight up I
swear to God like that may be a good
thing he was like oh I just thought that
this meant like you know we're grabbing
a drink and I'm gonna pay for news like
I know you're paying for names also that
doesn't mean it's a date yeah exactly so
yeah I just you people need to know I
think comedians too or in the
entertainment industry like they're kind
of like socially like don't you know
like you need to kind of teach them
certain things I think that's a lot of
people yeah a lot of that's why I like
now I like I have to have you like tell
me clearly yo like we got a date right
now like I'll ask you to like it was a
date yeah because I've been in that
situation for and I was like this is
really [ __ ] off I had asked Steve the
first time he asked me on it cuz it
wasn't clear and I asked my friend that
was like mutual friend I was like do you
think that's a date and he's like no I
don't think so he just got our
relationship I don't like see ya I
didn't know either but then Steve made
it clear he was like hey I'm gonna pick
you up in my car I'm paying for
everything you don't have to worry about
it
we're doing this like it is a date and
like he's very cool my god I can only
picture Nikki on her first date with
Steve she was like probably putting on
her earrings wearing a dress I had a
purse I never used a purse okay so I'm
like gene Z honey girls so like I had
jeans hoodie I never had a purse I'd
always put everything even now like it's
in my phone like I could put in my back
pocket and I put on a dress and a person
and and then after that I never used a
purse again it's like you need a purse
six and a half years yo and then your
friends for four years before that so
we've known each other for over a decade
ladies also take notes I mean Nikki is
very much in love with C Oh very [ __ ]
much you're so damn cute together yeah I
mean I kind of do have this year but I'm
hoping like in time I still have that
[ __ ] because I'm only like an hour and a
half into my relationship and I'm like
you're gonna have some good sign because
that's to me the make or break it mark
really yeah like where you really are
like I could do this forever or I need
to quit oh that's my leg too
yeah he's like my partner like any any
guy that I see just looks like like
dates like they have no face they look
like a Ken doll they have no penis
they have no like phase like I can't
even get law if other men are like
attractive and like that's how I know
I'm like so deep into it you know like
same
yeah that's you yeah that's good we kind
of grazed over the friendzone topic you
guys out there let us know if you guys
want us to elaborate on that because we
got stories I got stories just on Gina
alone yeah wanna dive into that for an
hour long leave it in the comments let
us know hit us up new games follow us
let us know all that stuff but um yeah
any more like any final closing thoughts
and I'm like there I'm like 6040 crazy
I've also friendzone people I have
series I'm the 60/60 crazy 40% a guy
like like yeah yeah 6040 okay alright
stories yeah I have friends owned people
hell yeah we believe that no we believe
you I believe this a genetic cream I
just say that if you hurt if you ever
get friendzone don't don't be a little
[ __ ] about it and get angry just take
it and go oh yeah move on okay but yeah
thank you guys so much we appreciate you
guys always showing us some love the way
that you can communicate that the
fastest is by giving us five stars also
leave comments share it with your
theater deals your girlfriends or
boyfriends and share it everywhere
you're are - yep there you go
you're Lola's repite abuelita's yep
exactly and I do want to say thank you
to our sponsors yes ShoeDazzle just a
little reminder at ShoeDazzle calm slash
b tch to get 75 off your first item holy
crap that's still really good thank you
also to Buffy that see that's uh Buffy
Co enter code b TCH to get $20 off your
buffy comforter and thank you to bone
Bozz thank you to hinge and thanks again
guys do you like
I want to be your friend but not with
benefits Kay